I got a yeast infection from staff in antibiotics back in June and July have eliminated fruit.
I take probiotics daily, as well as probiotic and fused coconut yogurt,
rectally and vaguely daily.
I've taken a whole bottle of kittis and forte.
I still have very itchy exoma on my eyelids, et cetera, et cetera.
One of my missing, how do I get rid of the yeast infection?
So Candida is a very difficult thing to get rid of because the systemic Candida is just a side of
other hill health too. So when you're doing other things like chemotherapy and all this stuff,
it's just really, really difficult. You have to just be patient with yourself.
You're doing all the right things. These probiotic confused yogurt,
rectally and vaguely, you're just trying to get probiotics at every orifice of your body
is what you're trying to do. And then just, you know, all the other good things that you are doing,
this is just a whole lot more that you could do.
We can't be adding more supplements to your protocol. You're just done so many things.
So wait till you get through the chemo, then we can discuss
possible leg steps without a...